hello and welcome to video playing Grand
Master ultra mate who is there actually
Emmerich on in rock on I'm not sure if i
pronounce that correctly there's also
german footballer of the same name with
turkish roots it's playing for from
liverpool if i'm not mistaken ok i
recently saw that actually taking is a
move but i'm not i'm not an expert at
all so I'm sticking with with what I
know night to e4 interesting you might
want to play a 5-4 yeah okay that looks
like a normal reply also f6 back at d5
might be an option no he doesn't want to
go for that yeah the question is 92 or
not not sure if I want to avoid that
trade let's play the standard moves
first and then then see what happens I
can yeah okay now i go back to you too
if you go see 5 then i get d 4 at the
end so get this i get the square now
which isn't the end of the world but
it's still yeah good to good to have um
okay I guess b5 and no particular reason
to delay this okay the one issue is I'd
like to attack c6 here but it's a little
bit difficult to move the rook at c5 is
hanging I want to really go to be 6 I
mean one thing if I'm mad f4 is a move
here but I'm kind of worried about bit
about f4 here
down g3 is very weakening
hmm ok i go for the immediate attack on
that porn ok he went back no I am if I
take at least okay you can take with a
rock now this is a right this is a self
then I know he doesn't do it ok let's
see if I and it's not pre move this is
that very risky pre-poo let's not do
that ok and why didn't didn't really
appreciate cringey five correctly huh
okay i can i'm still not losing stuff I
think
because he's sitting in a in a pin I
mean pinner that's 96 tactics so rook
takes a three Luke Texas reroute a
serious it's not working I have Queen d2
and wins oops why not why's that wave by
settable Queen d2 rookie 596 I thought
this winning isn't that winning could we
need to Queen d2 ablution aiding here
I'm completely elucidating oh my god I'm
only one ah how crazy can you be I'm
complete nuts what the heck how crazy
can you be amazing that's really amazing
okay so I'm taking this I really it is a
hallucination I thought Queen d2 is the
move and I was really calculating this
Queen d2 and he goes back and
everything's cool check in fact
nothing's cool I'm just I'm just
material down remarkable really
sometimes kind of stuff you can crazy
really crazy
check
check check hmm check check check that a
draw now did he screw that up I think he
did Jack King edge five is a self-made
yeah yes to make the draw now very lucky
in check after my ha ha yeah after my
hallucination oh my god I was really
think epic we did Oh crazy yeah here
this is some probably a roughly equal
position I don't think there's something
special going on yeah well this this is
some should be eight here and now the
capture I was expecting rook takes
actually the line that the engine is
giving I like four white engine wants to
play this move back at 93 i briefly
considered that idea but I couldn't I
wasn't really sure if this is doing so
much computer gives this despite a
slight edge I would really like this
position seems fine yeah this is
probably the other loop cakes was what i
expected i didn't expect that move and
now f4 is bad probably really really bad
ok i should go see 3 now I was totally
absolutely thinking I can't go Queen d2
now it's crazy and this is actually
quite funny if I go Queen d2 if I have
this moves erratically speaking rookie
five I have 96 which is a pretty nice
tactic yeah wins instantly with rook f8
made and every
hanging this is not a right this is not
a move and now I'm just I'm just lost
him it's very lucky that his stumble
onto into that into that drawer somehow
yeah he has to probably move the King
now after that it's a draw yes to go
here which is not so easy to do check
HERE the king is safe I can check here
he's running away yeah there was a
gifted half point I should really lose
this game after my lose the nation day
okay thanks for watching